you're editing them
because you've got a tiny little oh your
life is over you've got a tiny little
willy i have every advantage over you
from this point forward talk to me ah i
dare you
[Music]
while going guys happy monday
come on let's go guys uh i'm not gonna
waste time chit chatting i'm not gonna
fluff it up
real quick pause the episode real quick
do it now
don't waste any time pause the episode
immediately head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs you've got
a butt ton of episodes over there yeah
mom um that you need to catch up on and
then every thursday you've got a new
episode coming out first coming up
coming up um
and you need yeah you need to jump in we
we have fun conversations over there we
literally just recorded our most recent
one a second ago just before this and um
yeah me if you had gotten to a little
altercation
he got a bit messy i'm not gonna lie to
you gotta be here you gotta be here not
gonna lie to you so head on over there
guys um
it's three pound a month tempe a day run
the peeps
gigs go on over there enjoy yourself and
become a true member of the cult okay
um in the meantime guys if you are
listening to this on spotify apple
podcast google podcast um amazon music
wherever you listen to your uh your
podcast please guys please please leave
us a review give us a star rating even
if it's one star two-star whatever it is
just be open and honest uh give us a
nice review and it does wonders for our
algorithm it lets us get out there um
obviously we're blowing up at the minute
things are going well but
we need to hold as much as you guys as
possible so that when the algorithm
realizes we ain't [ __ ]
we've still got a nice cubbyhole
so yeah please leave us a review if
you're on youtube please like the video
subscribe to the page and chirp sitting
in the comments as always guys uh ring
the notification bell to make sure that
you are
notified when we drop new stuff because
it's going to be coming hot and fast
i know you guys have been requesting
another vlog
um which we've already booked in for you
okay so that's going to be coming up
pending pending sometime end of this
month beginning next month whatever uh
that's coming for you guys so look
forward to that
um and i guess without any further ado
we're heading over to final four eggs
for the um the fun fact facts of the day
guys what's what you saying people um
straight to it us bride and katora are
arrested for allegedly drugging guests
with cannabis
okay
allegedly indeed
so police in florida have arrested a
bride florida but yeah gone
police and floyd have have arrested a
bride and her caterer after finding they
allegedly added cannabis to food that
was later served to the wedding guests
the arrest came some two months after
the officials were called to the wedding
to assist the guests who said they felt
as if they were drugged
danny and the catered jocelyn face
charges of tampering negligence and
delivery of marijuana
officials say
oh sorry officials made the arrest after
testing the food and drinks from the
party the wedding occurred on the 19th
of february in the city of longwood in
central florida
responding deputies wrote in their
incident report that several several of
the 50 guest present reported feeling
weird after eating meatballs caesar
salad tortellini and bread will of olive
and herb dip
that's a thc
guests were complaining of stomach pains
and vomiting several were transported to
the hospital for treatment
one of the guests told the officers he
felt tingly his heart started to race
and he was having crazy thoughts
another kid
yeah another guest thought her
son-in-law had died and that her family
were keeping the information from her
she was taken to hospital where she
became loud and unruly and had to be
given something to calm her down
according to officials
the lady was taken was asked by police
at the scene whether she had allowed for
drugs to be put in the guest food and
she of course denied it
one guest
miranda kady
said she witnessed a member of the
catering staff adding a green substance
to a dish that would later contain olive
oil
it should be noted that miranda kady was
referring to what is commonly known to
as
commonly referred to as a marijuana
shake which is small scraps of the full
fall off large amounts parts of
marijuana
miss katie also claimed that the bride
admitted to adding cannabis to the olive
oil while while the pair were on the
dance floor the cage around her staff
and left before the police and could
question them at the scene
officials say that the bread and lasagna
were tested positive for thc
psychoactive chemical
a psychoactive chemical in marijuana
three other guests also tested positive
for the drug
medical cannabis in florida is illegal
is legal in florida sorry but not for
recreational use unlike some states in
the uk in the us
mad why would you do why would you do
that
she she wanted everyone to have a time
she wanted everyone to have a
merry-go-round
that's wild bro because like that's all
well and good
but like if it's not it's oh no it's not
it's not it's not it's not not the
action but wanting everyone to have a
good time is all well and good
she had good intentions yeah she had
good intentions but she's [ __ ] crazy
yeah yeah
um but like
when you're
to be fair it's hard because i don't
drugs but i can only imagine like
you
you will panic if you have no idea why
you're feeling right yeah feeling the
way you feel yeah yeah yeah you're not
expecting it whatever yeah you'll
[ __ ] panic bro man just dipping into
my main course bread and all my stars
bread and olives and i'm feeling tingly
and my heart's racing paranoid my
heart's racing
i'm just feeling hallucinogenic
man said i thought my brother-in-law was
dead or my son the family's keeping the
information from me that's crazy that's
psycho edibles i've never done animals
it's supposed to do stuff that's
psychedelic
brother that's that's different yeah i
know the um
i sound like such a [ __ ] i've never
done anything but um
yeah i feel like the
i've heard the the
they're eating it you've done edibles
right mm-hmm did you feel like
it's different
because i've heard it's it the the
psychoactive element of it is well for
me the psychedelic aspect of it didn't
really come to the forefront okay it was
just more
waved as opposed to a psychedelic oh
okay
i think that's more different types of
drugs which i've never done no but
apparently if you get the right yeah if
you get the right maybe maybe but for me
it's just never happened oh fair play
maybe my threshold is different yeah
i've heard people that take a couple of
these these gummies
they're on
[ __ ]
they're panicking
they're panicking nah i've never never
seen them never happened before but yeah
can you imagine being another wedding
though
for someone that you said has never done
drugs or anything oh my god i would
genuinely think i'm dying yeah i'd
probably go to the toilet and make
myself sick yeah because i don't know
what's going on going on you're sweating
profusely you can't see straight you're
dizzy bro imagine it's literally like
imagine um
imagine like you think you're just
having like orange squash but it's just
like alcohol in there and you have no
idea what it's basically this yeah it's
the jd apple another apple you think
you're just drinking apple juice backing
it back in it and you just get way
you're just laughing you're a bit loose
you feel different you feel spontaneous
oh because like you know the slow blink
you get when you're when you're drunk
that yeah
if i did that head rock if i did that
and i hadn't been in my it's
my soul is telling me i've not had
anything to drink i'll be like i'll take
the hospital because they're saying i'm
having a panic attack or something like
there's something wrong with me yeah
yeah yeah that's regardless of how i
feel yeah take me the [ __ ] off
now
but um this fridge bro
i made it worse okay it's cool
um oh that's horrible
am i oh bro that's i feel like
like i said to you before
they had good intentions but i feel like
that's taking the [ __ ] piss like why
on earth would you think that that's
anything acceptable maybe in like a
close-knit friendship group
and there's like four or five of you in
a yard
[ __ ] i'm gonna give you man brownies let
don't tell them that they're edibles and
see how they react yeah not your wedding
day brother bro you've got guests upon
guests why would you do that at a
wedding
in front of sounds the groom had no idea
it was the wife and the caterer they
thought [ __ ] it i'm a dib dab a couple
th season against the caterer on fam
they must have boys from before yeah
yeah yeah yeah
our wedding and the wife said look
let's just throw it out there's the deal
yeah you've got no choice at the moment
you've got no choice
everyone needs to get waved i'ma slip
you some thc
mix it into the ingredients pepper
grinder thing just just grind it on
there fam do what you need to do but
every man needs to get loose on this
edible thing yeah i mean you can't taste
nothing make it work nah brav
yeah they must have been yeah they must
have they yeah because they you can't
meet me for a consultation and say right
crazy thought just drug everyone
you want me to lose my license yeah yeah
yeah
you can have your deposit back i'm not
involved
i'm not involved yeah it rags here's
your deposit i'm not involved yeah i
hire someone else i'm not i'm not
drugging people i went to um i went to
one of my boys unis one time
um
it was not in her mind to visit him and
not on him and it was one of his one of
his flatmates birthdays okay and for
some reason they thought it'd be a funny
idea to put
viagra in his drink
no they did not said no they did not
they did they did
listen to me james you man couldn't do
that to me
listen to me james you man couldn't do
that to me
i
i would go for a piss because you know
when you haven't pissed for ages you go
hard a bit because
everything's rushed into it once i've
pissed and i'm still solid i would think
i need to go home yeah or i need to go
to a hospital i'll be petrified you just
got a rock solid boner for hours ages
bro i mean agony yeah he yeah he didn't
know what was going on oh and it was
dread as well because you see him
drinking and drinking it i i just want
to full disclaimer i did not participate
and i was not an accomplice and i was
against it
i was against i was gonna now that you
said you were against it i was gonna
know i'm sorry i was gonna know i was
gonna ask did you know beforehand that
they did yes they told me as they were
doing it i was not a proponent of this
and i was not an accomplice i was
against it it was against the whole
effort but the majority of voters yeah
but once he drank it yeah i was
intrigued to see what would happen and
i'm not going to like spectator sport it
was underwhelming but he was
grabbing his dick not like sexually but
he just needed to rearrange his [ __ ]
yeah yeah all the time the time oh and
it was just you could tell it was
stressing him out yeah it didn't make
sense yeah but yeah he could have had a
heart attack i'm i'm not surprised yeah
it was wild but um [ __ ] that man yeah
dragging someone that's
that's
that's more than a bit much that's a bit
much um right me before we move on to
trash news yeah yeah
random little
um
what do you want to call it i guess like
a shout out bit of love
non-sponsored little love shout out is
first of all it hasn't been as much
right so for context obviously you know
i live in the sticks yeah my delivery
services are
to say the least
say the least i've been there
my delivery options are not the best
you've got one chinese one indian a
couple mcdonald's yeah
literally there's two mcdonald's in
there for no reason
there's actually
yeah random burger joint yeah um two
mcdonald's a kfc and literally like one
indian one time
um luckily the chinese banks yeah cause
nine night 10 chinese don't back
um anyway
i use all three services i say all three
i use just eat delivery and uber eats
and some of the times they have they
they have different things on there of
course sometimes they have nando's on
there there's one one that's not on the
others and all these other things um i
will say though because i live on a new
estate
fam
because i live in a new estate you won't
believe the amount of drivers that can't
find me oh really their their their
system
whatever they're they're sat-napping it
just doesn't have my location available
on their phone oh mad so the amount of
times it's happened more than once
at times i've had a driver
bell me
and be like fam
i'm here i'm at this location
come and get your food i can't see where
am i going
come and get your food i've had to drive
like two minutes down the road to pick
up my delivered order no i'm furious
infuriating no
[ __ ] that infuriating
for that it defeats the purpose of this
oh i'll go to the restaurant and get it
fresh
i'll go to the restaurant and get it
fresh yeah if that's just what we're
doing
um
this is the game we're playing this is
the game we're playing i'll go myself
yeah because then i can have chips hot
salted and fresh and ready to go facts
you're sitting there letting the steam
marinate
the condensation just like dripping i've
had to leave my yard yeah yeah learn
petrol to link you and have an
link
to link you in the dark yeah to have a
weird little passover thing i don't know
what feds are watching
i don't need these man looking at my
business like that i don't need to pull
up to see a stranger to pass a package i
don't need this yeah it's sunday night
yeah come to my yard yeah so i'll give a
quick shout out uber eats ooby's never
let me down they've never bailed me to
come and get my food gang all the others
have gone going so ubereats
love you get your props for that yeah
props for that
uh whatever saturn have you used well
the system uses the algorithm yeah the
guys are always polite and they they
know where they're going so yeah thank
you for that
shout out you beats for that but yeah
you got a uh trash news though i haven't
got a trash news caption
mum oh mom start again man who fell in
love with his biological mum confessed
to wife they've had mind-blowing sex
several times
i'm gonna say that again jay say it
again
man who fell in love with his biological
mum confessed to his wife they've had
mind-blowing sex several times brother
a man who was adopted at birth fell in
love with his biological mother and
confessed to his wife that they had
mind-blowing sex several times kim west
51 had given birth to had given birth at
the age of 19 to ben ford 32 in
california
she gave him up for adoption 30 years
later they reunited and started a secret
affair
ford revealed the news to his wife
victoria
and said that he was going to leave her
for his mother he told victoria every
time i had sex with you since i met her
i imagined it's her i was kissing
otherwise i can't perform
right that's twisted of course it is of
course it is
i'm gonna say something controversial
out there i already know what you're
going to say well i already think i know
what you're going to say because i was
going to say something controversial as
well all right i'll say my thing all
right it doesn't correlate single thing
after bet
i'm not surprised that sex was my blow
it
that's taboo
i know what i was going to say but
continue not that i'm intrigued by it
whatsoever what i'm saying is um that's
illegal
in many parts of the world that's
illegal
certain parts of the world you'll
probably get stabbed for that yeah you
get beheaded
so that's a different level yeah
forbidden fruit yeah so i'm not
surprised it was mind-blowing yeah and
plus you're a psychotic yeah
you're psychotic yeah facts so
the fact that
this is all right let me put myself in
the mind of him for a second the fact
that you've met your mom it does help
that she didn't raise you as well that
was my point oh that was what i was
going to say continue but yeah i was
going to say the fact that you've met
your mum you're juggling these emotions
you don't know how to feel you just see
how she's [ __ ] [ __ ] you're banging
yeah that's what you're all you feel is
i love this one but i don't know this
woman yeah that's what's going in your
head
but you know it's wrong whatever's going
on your head you know it's wrong same
with the mum fam and then she
reciprocates
and then she reciprocates everything
goes out the window oh god everything
goes oh my god mind blowing is the right
one yeah mind blowing is the right word
yeah there's no other thing that can
happen be disappointed
you might shouldn't be doing this
forbidden literal forbidden fruit
wow
disgusting
disgusting but in your own little world
no one else can know
no one listen to me mum no one else can
know you better shut up
that's what he's doing if everybody's
banging her you better shut the [ __ ] up
because i need to not yeah
god
and he's a nut and i need to keep my job
i need to keep my place in society i
don't want to go to jail shut the [ __ ]
up
reciprocated yo but yeah what i was
gonna say was
obviously the fact that she gave him up
for adoption and he's 39 when she's 52.
there's been
a lifetime has gone by they don't know
her he doesn't know her she doesn't know
him
she just sees him as an attractive young
male yeah man and he sees her as a milf
and i'm trying to smash that's
disgusting it is disgusting actually
disgusted because obviously they know
he knows and she knows yo that's my mom
and yo that's my son
but fam it's even worse on her part she
physically gave birth she pushed him out
and now she's putting him back in her
that is insane oh is it's it's crazy
but yeah of course it was mind-blowing
there's no other way to describe it when
you said reciprocated my my wall turned
my wall turn because
i don't know how that conference like
how did they get there bro how did they
get there i'm gonna break something bro
how do they get there because
on the initial me let's say you've
you've sent your emails or whatever how
you've um however you've communicated
with her you've sent your emails like
mom i want to meet you rare tear because
he would know i'm i'm about to meet my
mum and the mum will know [ __ ] i'm about
to meet my son of 30 years that i gave
up for adoption
they link now they're whatever they're
in a cafe or whatever
let's say i'm the mom you're the one oh
okay it's a role play it's a role play
team i'm the son and you're the mum
yeah you said it you said it i can't
take it back you said it now i had to
reiterate i wasn't asking i was saying
i'm the mom yeah you're the son yeah
a local caf
off ends i don't know anywhere
peterborough let's say they're in
peterborough because this can't happen
in london i refuse to believe it happens
in london all right
you give london too much credit
you've said this many times about many
different scenarios that it can't be
london
i refuse to believe yeah this is london
it happened in like yorkshire yeah it's
a village yeah it's a village of offense
all right minimal electricity all right
one of them ones
i'm no mother yeah
so we've linked now
oh my god
i'll still call you james oh my god
james
you've grown up such a bee you've grown
up to be such a handsome young man give
me a hug
okay we squeeze up
she feels your back like raw yeah i work
out raw you work out what did i let go i
do i do i
[Laughter]
that's the first time i've ever heard
that because yeah i've not had another
kid after this yeah all right fair play
my first you i gave you away i know you
did i am so sorry but i'm happy we're
doing this cool let me ask you something
talk to me son why didn't you want me
listen why listen to me james listen to
me i was like emotional why didn't you
want me i was young i was 19
20 maybe
things weren't right my finances weren't
the best the person i was with at the
time didn't want to keep the u and he
didn't want me either
i was in a [ __ ] up situation i didn't
know what else i didn't know what the
best thing
that would be for you
so i thought instead of raising you up
in a shitty household i eat my household
i thought the best comfort of life that
you would get is for me to give you up
for adoption i'm so sorry i had to end
up this way but i'm so happy i got to
meet the man you are today
wow that was insightful thank you for
that i appreciate your truth and thank
you for that i i i'm so happy that you
do appreciate my truth because that is
my truth and i'm so happy you agreed to
meet me today so am i because like now
i'm here and i'm meeting you and i'm i'm
looking at you and stuff like that i
just
it will make me feel a little better if
i can ask this one question hit me you
can ask me anything i'm your mother you
can ask me anything i'm i wish that
um
sorry mom
i'm your mother you can ask me anything
sorry now that you've met me yeah
do you still not want me do you want me
to go
no no do you want me now no no i don't
want you to go but i also can't sit here
and say to you i want you now it's you
it's i think it's a mutual choice
whether we
continue to build on this relationship
cool
you know because i can't you you've
lived 30 years without me you have your
own parents quote-unquote you probably
have your own wife or misses or
girlfriend quote-unquote i'm single
and i've got my own life you know so i
can't force myself upon you and vice
versa so let's go with the flow i'm so
happy you agreed to meet me in this cafe
today but let's see where we can go from
here let me take it from there where
would we like where would you like this
to go from here i'm just throwing it out
there
one doesn't surprise me i'm just gonna
can i just be candid with you is this
still mother and son by the way yeah
okay can i be handed with you talk to me
son i'm listening right
we're both adults we are
i am not surprised obviously you're a
stranger to me so i feel like i can drop
the filter
i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised
that you have me so young because you
look young as [ __ ] somehow you've
managed to say in impeccable shape oh
thank you if i do say so myself i
appreciate it thank you so much when you
hugged me yeah
it was lovely
it was really lovely it didn't feel
motherly yeah it felt like i was hugging
an attractive young woman so well played
to you likewise
likewise because i felt you're back when
i hugged you and i
was like that's my son you held on a
little longer than i expected
you a little bit
yeah a little bit longer than i expected
yeah and when you say stuff like go with
the flow yeah what does that mean
because i know what it means to me yeah
what does it mean to you i just want to
i don't want i don't want to rush to get
to know you i want us to both be
comfortable so for us to get to know
each other okay because i've i made the
decision to let you go that was not your
choice that was my choice and i can't
rush
you back into my life i want us to both
agree to mutually take a path together
right
i'll be honest with you hit me
i don't feel comfortable in social
settings like this okay i feel
comfortable
at home potentially your home okay do
you live alone i do live alone
your home yeah
firewood
wine okay living room warm relaxed
setting relaxed setting we can make this
happen james can we go now
we can go now
if it's all right with you let's go now
all right let's go now cool
before we leave yes
when you're on your knees does it hurt
your knees because you're older than me
just randy i know it's
out there i just want to put you on the
spot yeah see what
see what happens do you need her
uh because you look young and healthy no
i'm very agile and mobile and flexible
gang
cool when you brush your tongue because
i have a weird thing when i brush my
tongue and makes me gag did i get that
from you
not from me it could have been your dad
could have been my dad could have been
your dad my dad has a
strong gag reflex you don't seem to have
a gag reflexes no it's i brush my tongue
to the the back to the depth to the back
to the tonsil
i'm nothing i'm nice and you're just
comfortable i'm comfortable
my tongue is clean
i i brush the whole tongue
cool sauvignon blanc does that work with
you i actually do prefer riesling but if
you like something young blanc no i like
stuffing we can go with whatever you
want to go for are you happy with the
respect my elders
hey are you happy with riesling whatever
we can do riesling i'm easy a nice
chilled bottle of reasoning all right
let's go home
and then there we are
i'm i don't really i imagine just
getting in
further than that but then my stomach
started to like bubble
because it's twofold because i'm also
talking to a man yeah and i'm also
pretending to be a guy
but i'm in an ancestral relationship
with my mom so it's just like
i don't expect
i don't feel comfortable in any aspect
of this i can't continue this
conversation basically so let's just
take it to the house and then the
viewers can imagine
i can't go i'm really i like our role
plays but this i can't take this any
further yeah this is too much
[Laughter]
this is getting a bit too much you might
get the picture though yeah
that's how we went down
[ __ ] it oh that's hilarious that's
disgusting
okay right ah so i want to move us on to
yeah so
so guys
you guys may this is a very it's not
very controversial so
recently
um
quite a well-known in the last 12 months
or so quite a well-known creator called
kevin samuels passed away indeed he did
i have no idea what he what harry passed
away it's still until dave speculation
really yeah like the last i heard of he
was
apparently he used to dis big things
like big females like bigger females and
he was last seen with a big female like
he went to bang a big thing in like a
hotel or something like that he could i
could be mistaken about it being a hotel
but i read he was with a big thing
before he passed away and the cause of
death is still undisclosed oh she said
she could have murdered man
i'm not putting words in anyone's mouth
yeah yeah it's a plausibility that's mad
because i had rumors that he was gay as
well oh swear
okay my room is that he was gay uh and
he refused to speak on it when he
interviewed about it which is fair
because he said it's irrelevant to my
work
so um but anyway okay yeah yeah hit me
so kevin samuels uh was a guy who did
very controversial content in terms of
he was supposed to be like a love and
relationship expert
um
but basically he was most famous for
more clips than anything
of just
women mainly but he did have men on
there as well
ringing in asking for relationship
advice basically scenarios in terms of
they're looking for this type of man
they want a man who makes this amount of
money a year they want this kind of life
they just want that
uh but their situation
in his opinion he would enlighten them
to the fact that their situation doesn't
qualify them to have the level of man
that they're asking for yes yes yes yes
and they a lot of time refused to
believe it which made for very
digestible content
um
so he's passed a lot of people happy
about it a lot of people are so happy
about it um
a lot of people are very indifferent
yeah i'm indifferent um
anyone's died but yeah i did enjoy some
of his clips sometimes because we have
spoken about him on the pod before yeah
pretty sure we have yeah of course we
have so what i'm going to do we've got
to my [ __ ] oh no we've got a dilemma
to read through today i'm going to take
on the role of kevin
read out this dilemma uh and then answer
it if you had to answer it as normal but
i will answer it
as what i think ever would answer okay
cool right so let me read it
right so this one is from a young woman
right so she says hey
i have a question
my boyfriend went out partying and
started following lots of girls that
night
following
well from what she goes on to say yeah
it's definitely social media okay okay
okay so i follow in lots of girls that
night yeah i found out after that he
messaged one of the girls asking for her
snapchat
he wanted nudes oh fam
i asked about this and he told me he
never spoke to them after but i've seen
it so i know he's lying yeah the girl
never replied but i still don't like the
idea of him asking for a girl's snapchat
am i overthinking this or is he not
trustworthy
i have a bit of trust issues because my
ex cheated on me i really love my
boyfriend so i don't want to ruin our
relationship because i overthink but to
be honest i am scared he'll cheat on me
someday please help me out
so for a reference let's bring it back
girl
in a relationship
loves him very much is concerned about
her own trust issues but has somewhat
somehow found out that her boyfriend on
a night out and started following on
social media girls that he met on that
night out she then saw a message of him
messaging one of those girls asking for
her snapchat and when she confronted him
he lied
so she knows he's lying she doesn't want
to ruin the relationship
but she's very very scared about getting
cheated on so doesn't really know how to
take it from here she just bury the
hatchet and move on yeah or should she
confront him again and admit that she
knows she's lying he's lying et cetera
um because i mean she loves him and
doesn't want to reload but she doesn't
also want to be taken from a mug um i
think off the bat because
like
i'm i'm answering this as me as a 30
year old man knowing the fact that when
anything gets moved to snapchat pause
and then begins character
okay and
you're kevin now yeah hang on
let me actually get into kevin yeah yeah
channel your inner chakra and then let
me know when you're ready
do your um fid show whatever you need to
do oh my god go fight these out oh my
god get fired
if anyone is asking me
or i'm asking them
for snap
i already know
nudes are being exchanged
regardless regardless of of whether you
want to admit it or not it's taking
something to another level because
with instagram you don't
i wouldn't say you necessarily
don't send stuff on instagram but with
snap obviously we know how snap works
you watch it and you can't watch it
again
it happens on instagram but i think snap
is more relatable because that's what
people have used for such a long period
of time you know and i think snap came
out before instagram if i'm correct
you're not correct i'm not correct
instagram but in the terms of
you what people use snap for
that was
the main source of crud was snapped
before instagram were being sent on a
snap away before way before is what i
was trying to say i didn't even
yeah i didn't even know if they had the
facilities the facilities for that
exactly so snap was the main thing so a
lot of people have snap but a lot of
people don't use snap like me i don't i
have snap but i don't use it you know so
the the
sheer fact that
she has clocked
that he has followed several girls
on instagram and has also clocked
she he has
requested
for a couple of girls snapchats
post this night out
what should she do oh she should leave
him
there is no
i understand the fact that she's been
cheating on before she doesn't want to
um
make him think that she's an overthinker
she also doesn't want to ruin the
relationship that they've got because
she obviously loves him she loves the
relationship but sometimes in life you
need to fend for yourself regardless of
the situation you're in you need to fend
for yourself and you need to protect
your own energy and i feel like she will
be doing herself justice as much as it
might hurt in the instance
of removing herself from that situation
i think in the long run it will make her
stronger
and she will know how to carry herself
and move going forward
kevin on to you what do you think thank
you for your you're welcome sir um
so yeah i'm i'm gonna be very cut and
dry about this i'm sorry if i offend
anyone
but the truth needs to be told facts
and can't wait
for
i don't know a cushion
all right so it's what i'm going to say
um
what you don't have there
is a high value man
i can tell you that for a fact yeah
a high value manual you don't have he's
a high value he doesn't value at all he
doesn't value you and he doesn't deserve
himself he's a bottom feeder yeah yep
what he's done he's gone a night out
he's seen some some puss that he likes
clearly didn't bang anyone that night
clearly
and his messaging girls for their
snapchat has followed the girls we don't
know if he got followed back or not true
he's he followed a mass amount to try
and get a couple back he went for
quantity over quality facts
he then messaged one of the girls asking
for a snapchat
and got aired
what you have there my love is a bottom
feeder a bottom barrel bastard yep
you have a b3 yeah you barrel bar
you got yourself a b3 yeah
that's that's red zone that is red zone
how does that make me feel as a woman
so what you've got itself there is a
very low value man
who
other females that he deems attractive
do not reciprocate his energy they also
saw him on the night out probably based
on the fact that he got ed probably
didn't follow him back
and then ignored his request for a
snapchat which they would have known
would progress to skin-on-skin visuals
so your main concern is that you love
your man so much that you don't want to
put
your relationship at risk by confronting
him with the truth
so what you've done is you've convinced
yourself that
your
partner is of higher value than yourself
is what you're saying yeah basically and
unfortunately you got yourself a man
that's like said he's a v3 he's bottom
of the barrel he's a b3
he's a bottom barrel bastard
yeah
you got yourself a bomb a bottom of the
barrel man
krill
is what you've got krill wow krill that
is the bottom of the food chain yeah
yeah yeah wow yeah yeah we'll call him
we'll call him krillin yeah krillin yeah
yeah literally
yeah yeah if this was because yeah
krillin for two reasons if this was the
the ocean and the food chain yeah he's
at the bottom yeah if this is draggable
z he's at the bottom yeah he just stays
dying wasting everyone's wishes yeah he
does you actually do have krillin right
i'm sorry get back
what you've got yourself is krillin now
krillin if you if you don't if you're
not a fan of dragon ball z let me define
krillin for you kritlin is the weakest
character one of the weakest characters
one of facts in the show and what he
does is he preys on people's sympathy
yeah because they know he's a b3 yeah
they know he's bottom of the barrel they
know that he can't defend himself so
every time these guys spend seven years
looking for all dragon balls they have
to waste a wish on reviving his [ __ ]
ass because he can't keep himself alive
he gets pumped up by every tom dick and
harry that want to confront him and then
they have to waste a wish on getting him
back to planet earth
and then once he's back he he he marries
an android he can't even get himself a
real woman he can't get married
android it is yeah i think it was
android 17 is it seven maybe i don't
know maybe i think it was 17 because 16
is the gingerbread
and it's either 17 or 18 which is the
guy in the guy that looked the same
basically he marries an android because
which is a glorified sex doll
basically what you've got yourself is a
crown you have a krillin you've got a
krillin okay and um
you do deserve better than that and uh
what you need to do
is vary against what kevin would
normally say to the women that he
typically speaks to on his show but you
are of higher value you are a rare
occasion where you're actually of higher
value than what you consider yourself to
be
and your man is a far lower value than
what you consider him to be
so you should stop worrying so much
about
missing out the relationship and
confronting with the truth the truth is
your man's out seeking next pump he is
he's seeking it and failing at it
miserably miserably
if he was of higher value then the pun
would seek him
and if he if he decides to be
um
weak
or selfish and decides to clap the
cheeks you'll never know about it you'll
never never know about it the pun will
seek him and he will keep his hose quiet
like will smith
he'll keep his hose silent
what you've got is a man desperately
looking for hoes and getting rejected
left right and center he's getting
rejected by strangers and your own
message messaging us saying you love him
honey that's embarrassing
honey let me tell you this that's
embarrassing
it's embarrassing to yourself
it's embarrassing to your self-worth
and it's embarrassing for me to have to
say that
i don't want to be put in a position
where i have to tell you that you're
embarrassing yourself
yeah
i've got a [ __ ] to do yeah i've got
other requests to deal with yeah the dms
are full yeah i'm busy i'm busy so what
you need to do is tell him
look
you're a b3 let's be honest let's be
honest
i've been dealing with you and i
actually do love you but what you've
done is you've disrespected me by
allowing me to see requests from you
didn't even delete the message big man
you followed all these hoes you didn't
get followed back
and then go through your phone and find
out that you're dm in horizon you're
getting aired
[Music]
what does that say about you it says
it says a lot it says you're a krillin
and basically
i'm an android 17
and i don't want to live my life as an
android 17. i'm a woman
a real woman i'm a woman i'm a real
woman i'm not glorified sex doll that
you can toss to the side so you can look
out for your street hoes i'm a woman
yeah and i deserve a man facts you're
not a man you're a b3 you're a b3
so sorry i feel like you're gonna have
to tell homeboy look i know you asked
for a girl snapchat that you met on that
night out don't ask me how i know and
don't
for future reference i do not condone
the way you found out yeah i do not
condone it what that information you
have is the information you have yeah
but i do not condone the way you got it
but anyway that's for another discussion
yeah we've been through that at length
yeah whatever yeah you found out your
man's b3
whatever way you found out uh and that
you need to address yourself
and um
yeah you need to let them know look
it's not the fact that you're out here
searching for pum
you're a young man full of testosterone
yeah it's understandable
but you got
pied
and that's embarrassing by several women
you got pied by several women women when
you had a wife at home that's extremely
embarrassing
and it says a lot about me if i stay
with you so what i need to do
is leave you to embarrass yourself by
yourself so i can find a real man
who uplifts me uplifts us both yeah so
we can both rise rise together yeah it
can't be like this yeah it needs to be
like this yeah facts and i oh
i don't want to give away trade secrets
but since kevin's been gone i'm gonna
i'm gonna leave with one piece of advice
that he probably never said maybe he did
it would do everyone a more
it would do
a lot better
when confronting a man for cheating if
instead you if
apart from the fact that you
approached him with the
how could you do this
what about us
all this stuff
victim mentality doesn't go a long way
with guys who are cheats yeah because
because they're cheese they don't care
yeah yeah they just feel bad because
you're crying
they feel bad in the moment yeah that's
because they got caught because they
feel bad that you're crying that's it
yeah
but what you need to do is be like look
the actions that you've taken i don't
know how to figure out in every every
situation is different but if you take
this one for example this isolated yeah
you're moving mad on social media and
you can't get [ __ ] to save your life
yeah and it's embarrassing and you're a
joke yeah that's embarrassing that
you're moving together and actually
can't even get to reply
so because of that
alone i'm out i'm out i'm out because
i'm here what does that say about me
yeah being with being associated with
you is humiliating facts so i need to
leave yeah so best of luck you're here
i'm barely above you but [ __ ] me are you
here you're krillin yeah you're krillin
you're
bottom of the barrel and i don't care
about you [ __ ] girls i don't care
about you moving to girls i don't care
about that but you can't you can't even
get [ __ ]
that's humiliating
i'm for that reason i'm out on a debra
medan thing for that reason i'm up i'm
out mic drop mic drop
i promise you that guy will step his
dick game up
listen to me james i'm okay and kevin
signs out and i'm back kevin james
what's up listen to me brother yeah i
can't
potentially try and cheat on someone
not be able to cheat on someone or fail
miserably fail miserably with multiple
participants
and get told that listen darling
i'm not condoning what you try to do but
the fact that you tried to cheat on me
and wasn't successful by five plus women
is embarrassing to me so i have to leave
you yeah i would break down oh james
will break down
because i'm not even vex that she's
caught me yeah i'm vex that because i'm
not buff enough i don't even get poor
i'm vex at myself i had a good thing
going at home and someone who loved me
and cared about me and made me feel like
a million bucks
and i took that and exploited it i took
that for granted by lying out i couldn't
catch anything i couldn't reel anything
in she said rawr
this is what i'm with yeah oh you just
made me realize that i'm with i'm with
nothing i'm with plankton yeah
you your actions alone have made me
realize that you ain't [ __ ] you are
bottom barrel and i need a real man
you're not oh wow you're not mad wow you
can't even cheat wow i need to leave
this relationship wow i need to leave
this relationship you actually can't
cheat wow you're incapable of cheating
for you can't even do it you're
embarrassing me you're embarrassing me
i'll break james as soon as she closes
the door i'm breaking down
oh you gotta oh you can't even cheat i'm
breaking down every guy cheats and you
can't even do that can't do that once
with me
i'm breaking down
i have to go i'm sorry i can't stay one
minute longer i'm actually getting leave
my [ __ ] burn it yeah yeah yeah burn the
juice
i don't want it i can't be associated
with you yeah i'm not taking anything
from this yard burn it or leave it your
choice any guy can cheat you can't even
i need a real man
ah
i think i'd go to jail oh one million
percent i think i'd go to jail i'd go to
hell because i'm killing myself yeah
i slipped my eraser that night because i
am worthless
if you can't even cheat successfully
what good are you to the world
what good are you to the world [ __ ]
that's embarrassing
wow
wow that was hilarious that was serious
you got into character yeah um speaking
of going through people's phones
oh okay we had or i asked an interesting
conversation or an interesting question
rather on instagram okay i'm ready i'm
excited so we asked what is the worst
thing you found on someone else's fart
and as per usual guys
we had
fantastic responses i bet they were a
fantastic response we had the typical
um
oh yo i didn't expect you to be that
good looking for a black girl for an
asian going off yeah you have the
typical nonsense ones or not nonsense
but you know what i mean
um but i found some some niche ones
that i'm recording my fancy
i'm ready i'm ready already
found sex tapes with his tutoring
students and he told me i was
hallucinating
so he found she found it felt she saw
the evidence confronted him and said
you're crazy that doesn't exist you're
hallucinating whatever you're looking at
on my phone right now it's not there
that's the home screen
that's the [ __ ] home screen your
business
i was like ra wow
i found her std results
that will rock me to my core oh my
god because how do you
what do you do do you confront them and
say i've gone through your phone i've
seen your std results and i know you've
given me something or do you just
pleasantly walk away i'm walking away
but do you give an explanation what do
you say um
to be fair i'm different because i'm
never letting anyone know i went through
their phone of course because i'm
already walking in at this environment
of course they've got ammo on me before
i even beefed it of course i'll probably
go and get tested
first i'll go and get tested i just
wanted to get tested because you know
yeah me and the boys i think i'd wanted
to get tested so i went with him for
more support and wow what did i find wow
kind of wait for us to lie like
like blame it all on me yeah and i'm
like you know what
do you actually know what's crazy about
this the real reason i got tested is
because you left your photo unlocked and
i found your std results mad crazy what
now
now what what now yeah so the only way i
put myself in a disadvantage is if i'm
already 100 points out yeah then i'll
let her have that one
because but she can at that point she
can't turn around i can't believe it
shut up
shut the [ __ ] up you must be crazy
that's the only way i'm getting to go
through someone's phone oh it's
hilarious all right bet
my mom's video my mom's video she sent
to an ex it was her and a dildo i was
scared
[Music]
i've got loads by the way sam i just
realized all right go go go
go go go go go go go my girl took a pic
of her toes through ripped socks
for whom
for whom that
i'll be asking myself that's the only
fans pick i'll be asking myself that
question brother three ripped socks not
even stockings
ripped socks
your mum your [ __ ] mother-in-law
yeah yeah nudes from his ex that he
claimed
nudes from his ex that he claimed he had
because she had cancer and he was
gassing her up to feel sex
[Laughter]
fam
cancer
that's a statement that's that's a dark
twist
that's a deez men will lie for anything
just to get themselves out of a corner
man game will
she's got cancer
she sent me them
so i could promote her because she feels
ugly so i said send me some pics
let me see what you're working with
she's dying yeah i was checking for
lumps mud
oh wow that's crazy
grinder on my boyfriend's phone whilst i
was pregnant
oh
oh
grinder
not even tinder bumble numb
wow
remind me to come back to that
but i'm gonna briefly do this
my supposedly straight friend had an
only fans where he rated dick sizes
my boy sitting in some singles
my boy sitting on some single mother's
face while his back was arched at the
camera
listen
i promise you i could never see that on
your phone
listen to me you would never see that on
my phone listen to me first of all
listen to me you fan first you man first
of all that's never gonna be on my phone
or ever happen period sam but continue
sitting on something yes face back arch
to the camera
just holding the back of her head
i know this podcast would end oh one
million i really like this it's not even
worth the money at this point
it's not even worth the money bro i
can't look you in the eye i know i know
a pic of his sister in lingerie they
were twins oh for [ __ ] sake
this one sweetened me i don't know why
an application to be on tipping point
for those i don't know what timber point
is it's basically date shitty daytime tv
for you to try and win some money and
it's like
why would you even apply to that so
ashamed shameful all these sex things
are hee-hee-ha-ha yeah but to apply to
be on tipping point it's embarrassing
embarrassing i could never find on
anyone yeah i couldn't find that a video
of my ex doing press-ups naked with his
morning glory
wow his own dick pic saved on his phone
and the edited versions
really really
and the edited versions
ah
i couldn't be confronted with that i
couldn't be confronted with that my
knees would buckle
big man
not only not only have i found dick pics
on your phone that weren't sent to me
yeah
you're editing them
because you've got a tiny little oh your
life is over
you've got a tiny little willy i have
every advantage over you from this point
forward
talk to me ah i dare you ah the edited
one i would go to jail cause i'd have to
fight yeah
that i can't let that mouth leave this
house
[ __ ]
gang bang porn on my mom's phone oh
the mom stuff is triggering me
i can't like even laugh at it bro
it's like i can't believe that's a thing
yeah yes nuts
mum was a freaky deak
this girl wishes
[Music]
this girl was vexed from the jump okay
go
a dirty [ __ ] saying she'd [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sorry one more time one more time one
more time
i'm so sorry go on
character guy
a dirty [ __ ] saying she [ __ ] my baby
daddy in mcdonald's car park in the
middle of the night
[Laughter]
fam
when women have a kid with someone they
would defend him no matter what no
matter what anyone who tries to
to [ __ ] this family up is an enemy enemy
of progress hurt a [ __ ] that's what
those were the first three words
[ __ ]
it's not his fault she hates her for
doing that to him
oh
this one this one reminded me of the
conversation we have we had before we
started recording our first episode all
right
saw my best friend had a private story
with all her close friends except me
oh so for context the reason why i just
said that for context one of our close
friends had um
he was wearing a suit in a close in a in
his close friend's instagram story post
i was like i swear i didn't see it and
he's like oh yeah james said to me oh it
was on his close friends i was like [ __ ]
imagine i'm not on his close friends fam
i pressed the ting with with easy i was
with fear and like oh my
even if even if i didn't see it i would
lie and say i saw it oh i want you to
because because we're going to dynamic
car we can't have this car i was at his
yard the other day yeah you were there
literally two days ago
so
you couldn't turn to me and blake fam
i honestly i can't see this post
there's no way we could just sit down
and record because i'd be like
i don't know what to tell you bro i
don't know what to do because it's not
your fault i'm just there yeah you're a
bystander yeah that's literally it
you really need to take that to head
office i don't know what to tell you i
need to say
for sure for sure anyway let me move on
that was jokes
proof his ex was warning me about
that he likes his ass ian even if it
means asking other men
wow ally my friend found out about her
mum's dominatrix side
saw a pic of a guy on all fours with a
mop in his arse a mop
man said get anything
get anything because i need it
what if you've got whatever you like
whatever you've got thick and long
quickly stick it in me quickly because i
need this a mop
and that's he found that on his mom's
phone
that's the third mum one now bro
photos of his wife and kids kids aged
eight and four months we've been
together for two years double life match
hang on i'm a reader again photos of his
wife and kids aged eight and four months
these are two separate kids yeah they've
been together we've been together for
two years double life much
mandem just don't care anymore they've
been together for two years man has a
separate wife and two youths one is
eight years old and one is four months
old
and we've been together for two years
things as well this is my thing with
double double lives
you haven't been together
i don't know what your definition of
together is yeah yeah but you haven't
been in her mind there together because
he's had a whole you yeah
he's had a whole you how are you but how
is he balancing both yeah it's
impossible your fault because you're not
picking up on red flags
she said oh but maybe this and but he's
not sleeping over there three nights a
week i'm telling you that
he's not sleeping over there for three
nights a week you've not been together
i found a breakup paragraph in her notes
ready to be sent i copied it and sent it
to her first
oh imagine i couldn't imagine reading
what i was prepped to send to her
i would drop my phone in in fear
imagine going through your girl's phone
and seeing what she's about to send to
you
never the draft version to let you down
easy easy
oh it will be a deadly day
it will be a deadly day oh god found
grinder on his phone early on
he said he thought it was tinder he
deleted it four years in i found one
again
yes brother
this is what the public are
oh there saying
years in i found listen i'm actually i'm
gonna talk on this topic now before i
continue this thing because
jokes aside yeah i think it's actually
so peak that certain men have to go
through this i was thinking about this
on the train while i was writing these
down okay so let's say for example i'm a
woman right
and i'm in a
hetero relationship like i've got a male
partner
and i sit my babes down and say babes
listen i have to talk to you
i love [ __ ]
but i also love [ __ ] i'm biased
bisexual as hell
as a
flippy i'm the man now the first thing
i'm thinking is i want a piece of this
yeah that's the first thing i'm gonna
think about we can pattern science we
can pat and sign to make you happy yeah
roll reverse fam i'm now a guy oh i've
sat down and i've told my mission baby i
love you i love you but i'm not gonna
lie i love me some dick too
bye she's gonna vomit on the [ __ ]
flying nine out of ten women say bye
she's gonna vomit on the floor yeah bye
so jokes this is what i say jokes aside
like man them that are getting clocked
with this grinder and this this gay this
gay situation yeah yeah yeah it must be
tough
secret it must be [ __ ] that's all i
was thinking about it must be [ __ ]
tough
fam good empathy you know what i mean
good empathy it must be [ __ ] tough
bro jokes aside james
jokes aside you man
because this man them go through this
yeah they do bro it's not easy certain
men don't know they're gay until they
know they're gay or they know they're
gay and they have to hide it yeah yeah
yeah i'm going to be with this girl for
x amount of years but i love this guy
and i want to be with her but she needs
to know i'm attracted to brazil i'm
attracted to braze as well as well only
i'm attracted to prayers only
i'm just with you by default
and it's not your fault but i don't know
how to tell
two girls
man said [ __ ] my cheeks poor sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
two girls one cup saved in his favorites
disgusting i promise you i'll call the
feds
that yeah that's that's detrimental it's
a criminal act yeah that's the wildest
video anyone's ever seen
no one likes that video not i've never
met a single person that likes happiness
that's nuts
he found me talking huh he found me
talking [ __ ] about how small his dick
was oh
so she batted herself out oh
scrap yeah hands
hands hands and
relationship done obviously
a video of my best friend clapping my
sister
you can never
i can never find a video on your phone
of you clapping my sister zay
is that hey babe
banging her stop stop saying that's not
okay sorry sir
moving on we're moving on
found out my best friend [ __ ] off found
out my best friend have fired baby
mothers he told me you only had one
on a future thing
bro
bro
that's to me stuff like that is worse
than what can ever happen in a
relationship
do i mean yeah because
a relationship there is somewhat
incentive to lie about certain things
but there never needs to be that between
us this is a judgment-free zone yeah you
can never tell me you got one baby mom
and then years down the line i've
actually got five five we're not boys
we're not boys
how could you do this to me yeah facts i
don't give a [ __ ] how many you could
have a hundred don't care facts facts
all right i've got about like 15 and i
just reel them off you can laugh you
cannot laugh your business how many like
15. i'm a real i'm i'm really all right
because we're on a time limit at the
moment yeah let's go a video of him
using my vibrator on himself
moving on a video of a girl getting
mentos and coke shot up her arm
for context guys for the scientific
context if you man have never seen the
chemical reaction between mentos and
coke google it and then run it back
google it run it back yeah yeah
bet
picks
pics of myself from almost a year back
because this girl had a crush on me and
stalked me
and that was a girl that said that
oh really
she invaded the friendship group
bollywood twister like invading the
friendship group had pics imagine us
that's a you thing the show
wow big man
videos of dad
videos of dad wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait stop subscribing i know we're
on a time frame
that's actually mad that's actually no
no that's actually mad because you
listen imagine imagine if we were here
right now doing all this yeah i put my
phone down yeah
and then i had some memories thing pop
up
i had a memory yeah the notification you
pressed it and it's you from when you
were like 12. just picks of me and i
definitely took those pics
james duncan 12 13 14. i'm scattering
this room
because there is no explanation and you
say what the [ __ ] is this when i walk in
i can't speak yeah
let me explain let me explain explain
stop saying let me explain a [ __ ]
explain yourself
i said
i said phone we've got business please
don't overreact
i'm not overreacting this is the normal
reaction brother
this is how a normal person is supposed
to react yeah yeah
videos of dad mum and son in a swingers
thing together and the son and dad
watched the mum get a train run on her
by ten men
i'm not laughing i'm not saying anything
say the next one messages from a bunch
of girls rejecting him
dread
pics of another ghost titties with bite
marks on it saying wow you were hungry
last night weren't you
oh
her blonde would boil
shane had it like that fam this one this
one she baited herself up videos of me
cheating on his phone
good
good
sorry she went through his phone and
found videos of herself cheating good
good but
that puts you in a paradox because he's
obviously not saying anything we're
living in a simulation
he's holding up for ammo yeah yeah the
next time you say what you're not done
the dishes swear i've not done the
dishes yeah say that
text messages from his mum saying how
much she despises me
[Laughter]
two photo albums next to each other one
solely for queen elizabeth and the other
for pure hentai
fact fan
fam
the general public
have seen some [ __ ] wow
queen elizabeth and hentai next back to
back no
i have to that's a get out situation
wow
my sister's nudes on his oh right listen
listen carefully okay my sister's nudes
on my ex's phone
he's now dating our cousin
man's run through the whole family he
don't give a [ __ ] he don't care about
any of you [ __ ] about it you're gonna do
what i want
your surname i just think you're all
banging and i'm banging yeah yeah yeah
this [ __ ] fell asleep with his dating
app open he was telling a transgendered
woman that he looked prettier than a
real woman and i'm gonna get her
pregnant
oh dear my love message that i'd sent to
my boyfriend he forwarded it to another
girl he was dating
moving on
moving the [ __ ] on
messages
listen to me james stop laughing and
listen to me
messages to a prostitute asking if she
was free for anal
these men are reporting
are you free are you free
that's a that's a rapport
listen to me james my husband's wedding
day picks with another wife whilst i
existed
listen to me james back back
in my bag
one of my girls had a video of a
stiletto going through a man's penis
blood squirting okay stop the next one
next
google oh [ __ ] it up google searches on
having a crush on my best friend's
girlfriend
imagine going on my phone and you type
in h8 and the first thing that comes up
in the crash with the the clock face
having a crush on my best friend's
girlfriend
can you imagine
i can't even imagine that fam to be fair
i would sit you down as a man i wouldn't
even be mad because you you're clearly
suffering with this yeah yeah and you
haven't taken action what's the what's
the word we spoke about um in in
internal conflict internal conflict
that's the thing your struggle is i
would say fam let's talk about it i
don't want to see you like that
[ __ ]
right give me two more
i'm gonna give you more than two we got
we got time you've got time i'm a brief
streak i'm a beast
go
a video of a guy beating his meat with
his ex's name written on his stomach
i'm gonna move on in pen i'm gonna move
on
they refer to me as fat emma
i'm a move on
i'm gonna move the laugh
that's your business i'm moving on
found pics of my girl giving my dad a
lap dance at his place oh no i'm gonna
move on no i'm gonna move the [ __ ] off
my friend's boyfriend's camera roll was
full of toe pics not feet toe picks i'm
a move on
found a pic on my ex's phone of his
friend's balls dipped in a cup of yogurt
i'ma move on i'ma move the [ __ ] on vids
of him i'm gonna move the [ __ ] off
because i'm gonna move on vids of him
and another woman calling him michael
his name is chris i'ma move on
i'm moving on james i've got four more
i'm moving on
a picture of his ex's titty in his mouth
i'ma move on
his own hand full of [ __ ] dripping off
like spiderman
i'm a movie
a shipment of guns and grenades from
somalia
[Music]
[Laughter]
picture of them a picture of them at a
satan cult party with an upside down
cross on their forehead
what fear would run through
i don't think you get it some of those
ones you get some of those ones were
west that somalia one
had finished me
i haven't laughed like that in my life
that somalia one finished a grenade
shipment from somalia
oh my god oh
guys guys girls thank you so much for
today that was an amazing episode thank
you so much as always guys head on over
to patreon.com for shits and gigs come
meet us on thursday and have some fun
with us
and uh as always love love love you guys
[Music]
you